[Musique]
antonine maillet tout d'abord au nom de
toute l'équipe du téléjournal joyeux
anniversaire 90 en gestation
et bien merci mais surtout ça va marquer
mon anniversaire je suis je suis très
content
pendant que notre cameraman simon
s'installer installait les caméras on a
jasé littérature et vous m'avez cité
cordelle m'a pays de shakespeare
visiblement encore à 90 dans la
littérature c'est votre ville et vous
savez je vous promets sa vie des jusqu'à
90 et vous viendrez mental vous allez
voir à quel point ce qu'on n'oublie
j'oublie les noms les noms je vous avais
vus à la télé déjà puis j'oubliais et
votre nom on oublie ça mais ça qu'on
n'oublie pas on n'oublie pas de ganesh
on oublie pas haché et riche et on
oublie pas don quichotte et on n'oublie
pas à bretaye on n'oublie pas parce que
on approfondit on les a assimilés
oui justement en tant que femme de
lettres et pour avoir lu plusieurs de
vos romans
on oserait vos personnages vous habite
et que vous leur parlez dans la vie de
tous les jours c'est un peu confus que
safran mais c'est tellement vrai que le
personnage à qui je parle le plus
souvent tellement que je la fais taire
ses radis à la 10 éme au double c moi
enfant est très souvent un radis ricane
quand j'ai dit des choses je l'entends
je dis d'accord d'accord je le dirai pas
elle est l'enfant qui me corrige
elle est mon personnage témoin de mes
vérités de mes manches mais vous
l'entendez pour eux c'est une façon de
parler
qu'est ce que c'est pour vrai j'entends
ce que je crée mes jeux créés ce que
j'ai entendu à l'intérieur de moi y
attend pas écrire des mots latins sur
les couvertures nos beckberger il faut
pas et versa guen parce que bien avant
que viola légère incarne le personnage
sur scène et sur un texte juste à ma
pauvre à du canada j'ai beau être une
salle win
je sais ce que c'est que nous y de
quelqu'un j'en ai vues 72 dans ma courte
vie
d'où vous est venue l'instant l'idée de
base dans un café à la maison comment ça
se passe dans votre talent
sachez passer graduellement et voulez
vous savoir un jour je suis allée chez
cette sarah qui m'a inspiré à ce bruit y
en a cinq ou six kilos qui m'ont inspiré
et à leur étage où il ya la caroline
mais ya ça va ils savent à mady elle me
tirait les quatre jours el mahdi a été
dans le coup tout le temps dans le
trèfle bien tout ça plaide ainsi tué
puis a dit y tonton souhaites tu voles
laouer tu voles la west on souhaite
savez vous ce que j'avais souhaité
j'étais en train de lui parler en ce
moment là et je souhaitais que là que se
trouve dans sociaux qui était à côté de
moi tout ce qu'est la dette qu'elle
n'avait pas dit mais qui était caché
dans l'autre sens où je souhaitais
d'achever cette chagrine qui l'a dépassé
et elle dit tu vas le voir qu'on
souhaite
ces foires vous savez pas ce qu'est des
personnes comme ça ça s'invente pas
pendant toute votre carrière vous avez
défendu la langue française et votre
peuple
votre peuple l'acadie quel avenir
voyez-vous pour l'un et pour long et
jeudi la mairie c'est cool qu'on emploie
nous mais moi j'ai 90 ans et j'ai encore
devant moi peut-être dix ans les
médecins modifications à vide
j'exagère mais ils y ont dit deux
médecins qui se connaissaient pas le
montre remise encore jusqu'à ses envies
de toute façon l'avenir c'est ce qu'ont
fait chaque nous maintenons puis
maintenant on peut décider si on va
retourner au moyen âge ou avant le moyen
âge retourner à l'époque où on le
gardait les étoiles vous savoir le
lendemain et bien sinon est ce qu'on va
devenir des machines des remous
peut-être au bout vont nous remplacer
et bien c'est à nous de décider et moi
j'ai toujours vu le beau côté de la lune
et jeudi même si ça arrivait sa livrée
pour un temps et le temps c'est quoi une
fois qu'on est mort j'ai tellement
abstrait le temps maintenant qu'est ce
qu'on vous souhaite pour votre 90e
anniversaire
et bien moi si c'est moi qui souhaitais
je dirais que le monde se met à
ressembler à ses rêves - j'ai voulu
c'est ça que je me suis souhaité que le
monde se mette dont assemblée à mes
rêves je dis ça à tout le monde
souhaitait un monde qui souhaitent qu'il
semble à vos rêves mes rêves est bien
vrai mais les artistes ne sont jamais
dieu sachez ça c'est le seul métier au
monde où l'artiste aura le dernier mot
le miey chasseurs de dire déjà mort
[Musique]